[Musique]
marmaille longtemps la montane intime en
faisait des titres mythiques du
mouvement culturel basse terre c'est
avec plaisir que l'on replonge dans ce
répertoire musical avec thierry gauliris
le leader charismatique de basse terre
ici à saint pierre
[Musique]
elle a déjà merci thierry gauliris
accueil à noter a lâché ou alors la
première cassette de basse terre la
ressortent en vinyle cette année
pourquoi il a voulu faire ça met de new
york est niée d'époque à cette ligne
ltée des leviers de munich ou de presse
que plus belle musique et à nous quand
même une telle vinyle obligé même tient
là fait qu'il fallait avoir été
l'occasion de marque aussi les 40 ans de
l'association mouvement 15 mai 1981 2000
21 40 ans au sac finalement ce cd la
india nous voilà et lui traverse le
temps et jordi c'est l'occasion de
rendre hommage à mon visa à un mouvement
que le nez à cette époque à des dizaines
de 80 et si youtube a dit à l'ats jérôme
cousin me l'a peu mieux parce que jordy
l'ex nous est vraiment son lit son sens
ce beau gazon rudipontain bastet effet
comme midi toujours à l'europe bien
d'autres musiques ou un master faut
connaître quel ton monte carlo car mon
mari canal de l'otsc michon finalement
et mais le côté vraiment au sac nous
exprimer nous montrent un mouvement
musical d'un mets tes baskets aussi
l'amant et écouteurs beau mâle mal
service camaret mais dire que ça fait un
projet en commun de la musique en avant
n'avait point
[Musique]
183 la première cassette que ça on
retient de ça le souvenir le plus fort
que moi c'est c'est vraiment là par
exemple premier coûte le fond musical la
ra madame vraiment 83 ou ça que nous on
l'était dans le petit case en tôle
labéraudie côté de l'église saint-pierre
là bas mais ça qu'il fallait attendre 11
et demi pour enregistrer parce que ce
n'était pas d'un studio et à cazes le
technicien temps bat philippe de manier
l uimm tyrolien et là tu es prise
directe quoi
[Musique]
il
ça
mettez dans la revendication monsieur
tout ça qu'il faut dire où nous n'est en
tout cas mon expérience de la vie c'est
que comme et comme ils y arrivent
l'école où ça que me comprend que la
langue créole c'est pas le long coup de
l'utiliser il est un peu bizarre pour
moi parce qu'il m'arrive l'école vidéo
que le monde finalement sur montagne
appartient pas où et c'est parce à coude
à cause des ses potes histoire santé
enseigner c'est pas honteux géographique
d'être enseignée vous dites est là il
faut trouver une manière combattent
aller en guerre mais non mais ça laguait
avec un roulé avec ma guitare pour dire
de monter une écriture d'un allons le la
d'histoire
non
[Musique]
l'essentiel a été fait en tout cas pour
moi mais après faut continuer continuer
nous un moment même la lah passage
passage du flambeau c'est à dire la
folle aux jeunes générations et continue
même à des groupes qui fait le décompte
fait pas et puis si chacun selon son
histoire son vécu aussi peut-être
peuvent être impliqué auprès des plus
jeunes ouais mais ça ils amènent les
marmailles à en 2h26 à trois fois trois
quarts d'heure parce que au bout de
trois quarts d'heure ni fatigué c'est
marc mathieu 2 au cm 2 de 5 mégawatts
tout du moins il peut composer et tout
le monde peut écrire aussi mais n'écrit
pas n'importe comment
tiens il faut que les emmène un peu
position de la tête pour son odeur c'est
à dire le donne le meilleur de nous
mêmes à lui conviennent une phrase vise
la réussite et oublie le succès est ce
qui caractérise haoussa le succès pour
moi l'éphémère alors que la réussite
c'est sako finalement qu on réussit ou
bon sans prétention aucune
où les quelque part un peu modèle en
tout cas il est vrai qu'on ne roule pas
si l'on n'essaie rempli mon fils d'un
père mon loyer tout ça mais bel et bien
ou mal et comme il fait la musique
surtout être marmaille avec une bonne
camarade bonne bien ap un mal nicolas
2001 qui change c'est à dire la musique
voilà c'est un choix de vie mais
malheureux merci de série on espère
qu'on voit reste un modèle de ravoir
house bientôt sur celle ci